non écoutés pour nous la priorité c'est
une relance
nous avons bien vu en 2020 avec une
belle bête pib d'à peu près 10 % puisque
effectivement il ya eu moins de travail
fourni mois de richesses produites par
le travail et donc moins de cotisations
sociales en rentrant dans les caisses de
la sécurité sociale donc effectivement
il ya un problème en 2020 1 25 milliard
en moins pour la retraite du à cette
baisse de 2 quantité de travail fourni
en raison de la crise sanitaire
donc ça c'est un problème en soi bien
entendu mais ce que l'on sait également
c'est que si tu leur faire de la
politique fiction si nous avions eu
cette année
cette retraite par points qui étaient
déjà en vigueur et guin probablement que
les pensions des retraités auraient
elles baissé de 10 points également
cette année et donc on décolle sur un
système protecteur qui a fait que le
pouvoir d'achat des retraités a à peu
près été maintenue aujourd'hui et ce qui
a été un moteur important pour la
consommation notamment en cette fin
d'année
là on s'intéresse pas 2021 on
s'intéresse pas à 2022 on s'intéresse à
2020 on s'intéresse aux aux prochains
jours aux pros prochaines semaines qui
seront cruciales pour un bon nombre
d'entreprises et du coup bon nombre de
salariés aussi pour aujourd'hui en
france on est dans un système de
répartition et je pense que c'est
important de le rappeler le système de
répartition sont les actifs qu'ils
cotisent pour les retraités et
aujourd'hui on a un gros sujet de
démographie en france puisque dans les
années 60 on était à peu près quatre
actifs pour un retraité aujourd'hui on
autour de 1,6 1,7 et donc la question
c'est comment est-ce qu'on finance
comment est-ce qu'on finance a déjà en
temps normal est encore plus entendu en
temps de crise donc il s'agit pas de
faire des économies sur le dos des
français de bien sûr que ces sujets
reviennent en boucle mais de se poser et
de se dire comment est ce qu'on peut
assurer aux français que notre système
des retraites
il est pérenne
bien sûr que c'est une à un sujet
brûlant politiquement je pense qu'il
faut le leur prendre avec beaucoup de
calme
ce que n'a pas fait le gouvernement
depuis le début où on à agiter des
chiffons rouges on a parlé d'un système
à points ensuite on a dit qu'on voulait
mettre un âge pivot fallait on a eu
aucune clarté sur ce sujet donc je pense
que 2021 va être l'occasion et j'espère
en tout cas de remettre les points sur
les i de reposer les termes du débat et
peut-être jeu de consulter les français
par exemple ce qu'est notre position
chez objectif france avec rafik smati
nat président par référendum
parce que c'est un sujet qui va engager
les dix vingt trente quarante cinquante
années à venir et donc il faut consulter
les français mais il ya un problème
d'emploi dans l'autre pays
la crise économique est l'urgence
sociale du moment on va naître c'est
comme ça qu'il ya un creusement de la du
chômage des problèmes de l'emploi de
suppressions d'emplois et donc l'urgence
à mon avis n'est pas du tout pour le
monde du travail mais également pour le
gouvernement n'est pas réformer le
système de retraites c'est bien de mener
la bataille de l'emploi la rémunération
du travail et de la formation
professionnelle ou si je pense que pour
maintenir
voilà une qualité une quantité de
travail dans les années qui viennent
il faut mettre l'accent sur la formation
professionnelle et c'est ça c'est un
sujet dont on n'entend pas du tout parlé
par le gouvernement par exemple
il faut pas opposer les générations on
compterait on a besoin des uns des
autres les générations sont liés notre
destin est un peu comme un même en
décalé dans le temps et moi je fais le
pari que la compétitivité la technologie
etc permettront de financer des
richesses futur pour une croissance
davantage verte
évidemment et que ça créera des emplois
et qu'on parle continuer à cotiser et à
financer la retraite de nos aînés voilà
je pense que c'est cette confiance qu'il
faut avoir aujourd'hui maxime avant ce
discours là je pense que le fait que le
vaccin arrive également en france il est
arrivé aujourd'hui ça peut être facteur
d'optimisme quand même se dire que voilà
fouette un peu rationnel que des choses
vont probablement s'améliorer les
retraites c'est un vrai sujet et les
sujets importants devaient être mis
devant les français donc j'attends des
démos courageux je ne sais pas si
gouvernement sera capable
et si je puis me permettre j'attends
également en tant que jeu encore une
fois il n'hésite pas de proposer les
jeunes contre les vieux et souvent fait
pendant cette crise due qu'au guide mais
je crois qu'il faut s'adresser aussi aux
jeunes je parlais des générations
futures je parle avec les voilées et
aujourd'hui on a un peu l'impression
avec tout ce qui va relever de la clause
du grand père c'est à dire que les
retraités ou les gens proches de la
retraite vous devons à priori pas être
touchés par cette réforme
on a un peu le sentiment nous les jeunes
de payer d'être juste là pour passer à
la caisse et pour payer pour une réforme
sachant que nous mêmes on a aujourd'hui
absolument 0 garantie de demain pouvoir
espérer toucher une retraite même si
c'est pas notre ambition notre ambition
c'est de travailler c'est pas 2 c'est
pas de toucher une retraite mais ne
faudrait pas que dans cette réforme les
jeunes soit la variable d'ajustement du
gouvernement c'est une de mes craintes